hi my name is amit sahai and i'm a
professor of computer science at the
ucla samueli school of engineering today
i've been asked to explain zero
knowledge proofs in five levels of
increasing complexity a zero knowledge
proof is a way for approver
to convince a verifier that some
statement is true
and yet reveal no additional information
beyond the fact that the statement is
true zero knowledge proofs are being
used in blockchains and cryptocurrencies
so cryptographers are excited about zero
knowledge because of its amazing
mathematical properties but also because
of its incredible applicability to so
many different scenarios
[Music]
what's your favorite subject i'd say
math some of these small problems can
actually be really big and complicated
it's like a puzzle i love math for the
same reason today i'm going to tell you
about a thing called zero knowledge
proof so in the zero knowledge proof
there are two people there's approver
and a verifier and i want to prove that
something is true to you but the weird
thing is i want to prove to you that
it's true without telling you any
reasons why i remember when i first
heard about it i was like wait what how
could that possibly be right yeah so
what do you see in this photo a lot of
penguins yeah hidden among all these
penguins is a puffin do you want to try
to look for it do you see where it is
hmm i know where it is but i don't want
to tell you do you believe me
you're not sure to believe me right yeah
but what if i could prove to you that i
know where the puffin is without
revealing to you where it is let me show
you
i took that photo that we showed you and
i put it behind this poster here why
don't you go take a look through that
hole
i see the puffiness so when you look at
this board we don't know where the photo
was right was the photo like with the
corner here in which case the puffin
would be all the way at this side or was
the photo with the corner here because
the buffing would be on the other side
so this is a really simple example of a
zero knowledge proof i convinced you
that i knew where the puffin was
but you didn't learn anything else why
do you study zero knowledge proof when i
first learned about them i just thought
they were so cool but it turns out
they're also really useful not just for
finding like puffins if you just type in
your password and the hacker hacks into
the computer they can just get your
password right yeah what if instead we
could somehow use a zero knowledge proof
to log in you would just be able to
prove
that hey i'm chelsea without revealing
anything to them if you could do that
then it would be amazing right yeah
because then even if the hacker hacked
into the computer he wouldn't learn
anything because even the computer
doesn't learn anything so chelsea in
your own words what is azure knowledge
proof zero knowledge proof
is proof to a statement you don't show
them why or
what you just show them a tiny segment
or
just do some sort of
weird magic trick that's not really a
magic trick
and they will be convinced and you
didn't show them why or anything like
that
so have you ever heard the term zero
knowledge proof before i have not no
right it's a way for approver
to convince a verifier
that something is true without revealing
anything about why it's true which
sounds totally bizarre right like how
can that possibly be what i want to do
is prove to you that i know this
combination without revealing the
combination to you and what you could do
is you could write a little note a
secret that i definitely wouldn't know
fold it up stick it in here and then if
i know the combination i should be able
to open it and tell you what you wrote
all right
there we go
so
my dog is named doug did you figure out
what the combination was no so nowhere
in this interaction did you
see any information that you didn't
already know and yet i convinced you
that i know the combination
right yeah so
what's the exact purpose of azure
knowledge proof is it like
proving something but without giving
enough information that could
endanger whatever it is you're proving
so you're asking like why shouldn't i
just share my secrets with somebody
people don't trust each other and if i
was able to prove that i've done
something correctly
to someone without having to reveal my
secrets then that person would trust me
more how does this relate to computer
technology like do you type it into a
computer and somebody else receives it
or is it an in-person interaction
suppose you wanted to exchange messages
with someone that you knew what would
you guys do you'd probably first get
together and like figure out some secret
code right and then like write messages
to each other in that code but what if
you've never met the person before what
if you want to exchange secret messages
with me and we've never met each other
before how could we possibly do that
i have no idea it sounds impossible but
it does
but it's not we wouldn't use like a
physical lock or a physical box we would
instead use mathematics to do these
kinds of things you could take a message
and encrypt it using mathematics and
then i could prove to you that i know
the key i could open it up and send it
back to you that way i would be proving
to you that i know the mathematical key
to the mathematical lock box so based on
what we've discussed today in your own
words what is a zero knowledge proof
it's like if you have this really
important secret that you want somebody
to know about but you don't want to tell
them everything you can use as your
knowledge proof to prove to them that
secret but not give away all of it
[Music]
what are you studying i'm a first-year
computer science student at usc viterbi
i'm interested in all things like data
and internet and blockchain and
cryptocurrency have you ever heard of
zero knowledge proofs only in passing so
actually in the blockchain space is one
of the spaces where we are seeing zero
knowledge proofs being implemented and
uh and i think it's just the beginning
let's talk about zero knowledge proofs
at its core a zero knowledge proof is an
interaction between two people then i
should be able to convince you that some
statement is true but you won't have any
idea why it's true well like understand
that it's true because like you know the
operations performed in the proof are
like of a certain like you know they
have like certain attributes that would
make them true what you're basically
asking me is wait what
right right so this is what makes
cyrano's proof so fascinating and so
counterintuitive and i think the best
way i can
i can explain it to you is by by means
of an example but before we do that
i have to decide what i'm going to prove
to you in a with a zero-knowledge proof
and the way we're going to approach this
is through something called np
completeness what an np-complete problem
is it's a problem that's really hard to
solve but if you can solve it you can
solve any problem that's in the class np
and that includes a vast number of
problems and what we're going to do is
we're going to use an np complete
problem to actually prove
an incredible variety of statements
through a zero knowledge proof and the
specific and complete problem that we're
going to be looking at is called
map three coloring okay so here we have
a map okay
and these are a bunch of countries and
we've arranged them so that no countries
that have the same color
share a border that's what makes a
map like this
validly colored and now you might think
well why should we care it turns out
that
whether or not a map can be
three-colored in this way
is an example of an np-complete problem
and it turns out that you know maybe
what you really want to do is you want
to give a zero-knowledge proof
that you have at least point three
bitcoins right that would be cool yeah
without revealing what the address is of
your of your account it turns out i can
take that statement that i have at least
point two bitcoins
and convert it
into a map of countries and that map of
countries
will be three colorable like this
only if
you have at least point two bitcoins how
would we turn something like this into a
zero knowledge proof of course the first
step is we have to erase all the colors
what i've done is i've put a color
inside each of these envelopes now how
do you know that it's a valid coloring
you don't right you have to pick any two
neighboring countries you can pick them
however you like at random can i get
these two these two all right sounds
good right here we have green
right
and over here
we have blue
okay and as you can see there are two
different colors right so you have a
little bit of confidence right that i
have managed to color this correctly but
not that much confidence because i've
only shown you two of the countries yeah
right
so now of course one way to get more
confidence is to open up more of them
for you but that would be revealing
information to you i don't want to do
that so instead i'm going to ask you to
please turn around
and now let's change up these colors can
you pick two countries at random and
we'll reveal to the colors again okay
this one and this one nice and they're
smart of you to check with the same one
of the ones you already had right
but as you will see now
it's not
green it's blue
and this one on the other hand
is
three
okay the colors i showed you last time
don't work with these new colors right
this wouldn't have worked yeah because
of this one right exactly right but it
works for this coloring that i'm showing
you right now so what we've done is
we've made it impossible for you to put
the pieces together and if you do this
let's say a thousand times
and if i correctly showed you different
colors
each thousand times
you'd be really convinced and that's it
that's the entire zero knowledge proof
oh okay so
is it like there's no like actual like
explicit like step one step two step
three it's just like a probabilistic
yeah in actual implementations we
wouldn't use envelopes we would use
encryption right but it's really this is
the protocol so what are the broader
implications of like zero knowledge
proofs are they supposed to be like more
practical for like implementation and
are they supposed to like structurally
prove something it's not about making
something more efficient it's about
doing things that we just didn't know
how to do before i can actually prove to
you without revealing to you any of my
secrets that i use to behave honestly
right i could prove to you
that
i signed some encrypted document
correctly right without revealing to you
what that secret document was that
ability to change the game like really
just change what we can do is what zero
knowledge brings to the table where do
you think we could build like more trust
using like zero knowledge proofs and
like its implementations one great
example is like in elections if you
could prove
that an election was correctly conducted
that every vote was counted and it all
added up to one person winning with a
particular total
in zero knowledge then you don't have to
give up the actual votes of any person
and yet everyone could see that hey yeah
it was done correctly
it's so great to have you here and talk
with you eli um can you tell me a little
bit about your research my research
is in cryptography specifically i'm
working on some various multi-party
computation protocols the one i'm
working on right now
is a system for computing aggregate
statistics so that service providers
like google chrome or tesla
can collect those statistics
without learning anything about
individual users data that's awesome i
as a user don't have to let firefox know
that my favorite website is
mylittlepony.com
but they can know how many users go to
mylittlepony.com every day that's near
and dear to my heart not a party
competition obviously zero knowledge
proofs are about proving things to
another person without revealing the
details of what it is that you're
proving but you know in my mind zero
knowledge actually goes even further
beyond that it's like this overarching
concept that you can see a lot in
multi-party computation where
you want to accomplish some sort of task
without revealing anything more than
exactly what you need to accomplish that
task right and it allows you to prove
that you've been behaving honestly
without revealing any of the secrets
involved
that you used to actually behave
honestly so we of course know that zero
knowledge proofs for np complete
languages play such a huge role in
cryptography i'm curious what was your
first experience with empty completeness
like yes so my first encounter with np
completeness was in my very first
algorithms class that i took as an
undergraduate so that was my first
introduction is that an np complete
language is this amazing problem that
not only tells you about itself but
solving this problem can actually tell
you about an entire class of really
interesting problems we first started
thinking about proofs as an interactive
game where we're talking to each other
that made journalists possible
absolutely right yeah and
and the idea that randomness
could be useful
for proving something again seems so
counter-intuitive if we think about this
platonic ideal of a proof
right there's no randomness there's no
non-determinism that's present there and
it has to do with you know this whole
idea of flipping a proof on its head you
know in an old classical proof
randomness is specifically against the
goal of what you're trying to do right
because you're trying to make everything
obvious and you're trying to reveal the
flow of information indeed but once you
flip that on its head and you're no
longer trying to do that suddenly all of
the bad properties of randomness become
good exactly right because randomness is
unpredictable and that's what we want
right we want that unpredictability
randomness to be utilized to actually
hide the information that we want to
hide how have you used your knowledge in
the projects you've worked on what are
the challenges that you find in my
experience usually the hardest part is
figuring out exactly where the best
place is to use it i've written some
papers in the past that have used zero
knowledge in a more theoretical way but
when it comes to applications
some of the most exciting applications
that i've seen so far have been in the
blockchain space so what are some of the
efficiency bottlenecks that you find in
terms of efficiency
uh one of the coolest things about zero
knowledge proofs is that there's so many
kinds i like to call them flavors i
think that in general when you're using
zero knowledge proofs in application the
main bottleneck tends to lie on the
approver can you take the provers job
and split it up into lots of parallel
computations right that's such a fun
question it's such a great question and
yeah i think i think we still don't know
the answer to that as a field one of the
coolest things i've seen over the past
you know three or four years when i've
been working on this kind of stuff is
the transition
from
theoretical to applied and seeing all of
these amazing
systems that people thought of in the
past 30 years
start to actually get efficient enough
to be actually made no doubt and
especially with cloud computing
exploiting the power of the cloud
to enable zero knowledge proofs and to
make use of journal electricity would be
amazing right and
also in the blockchain space for example
if you want to speed up the generation
of proofs if that could be done in a
distributed way then that would be great
one of the hopes that i have
is that the power of multi-party
computation is about bringing people
together who are mutually distrustful
yeah right so can we
take that power that's there in the
cryptography and use it to somehow help
with the tremendous level of mistrust
that exists in society right now in
helping to bring groups of people
together i think that's one of the
reasons that i was so drawn to
multi-party computation in the first
place in my mind one of the most
important problems in the world is the
fact that so many people don't trust
each other and to be able to actually
use math to create technology that can
allow people to work together without
having to trust each other is a really
cool and awesome mission i think
it's so great to see you again i think
last time we met was in 2017 or
something like that i think we zoomed
once during the pandemic but
it's good to see you in person right
absolutely and
actually in 86 i was taking a crypto
class with professor edelman the a of
rsa and he assigned me the paper by uh
god of wasabi charlie redkov zero
knowledge proof so that's indeed my
first ever presentation ever in this
country it was about zero knowledge
that's what's up on zero knowledge yes
such a almost hypnotic concept it's also
an interesting um
way how mathematically to formulate
those concepts right for example
we have data then eventually we said
that from data like data mining you can
get the information and then you have
this word called knowledge right right
so knowledge has been long debated
even in philosophy what is knowledge but
here is in a very fascinating way
mathematicians or computer scientists
right want to somehow capture knowledge
they didn't say zero information proof
right so so what's your take on why
knowledge is rather than information or
zero data proof clearly this data there
so can't be zero data absolutely i don't
think we still have a completely
satisfactory answer to that question
what was so such a beautiful insight as
i'm sure you know
is that the idea of
zero knowledge
being something that you can already
predict right if you can already predict
the answer
then you must not be gaining any
knowledge by that interaction this
insight of
being able to predict the future
accurately and that being an evidence of
a lack of new knowledge was such a
beautiful insight such an amazing
insight why not zero information here
fundamentally i uh clearly from
computing perspective security
perspective it's a how much knowledge
you gain i guess more than how much
information you gain and how much data
you have right so that big data doesn't
immediately imply
a knowledge but people can sometimes
right sometimes i mean for example in
medical research how amazing would it be
right to be able to
have a drug and be able to prove that my
drug works in this model and yet not
have to actually reveal the structure of
the compound what uh currently
you think it would be the next
directions in
one of these next big things
yeah this concept of zero knowledge
programs
would allow you to carry out completely
arbitrary computations in a zero
knowledge way without any interaction
right i can just take the program
convert it to a zero knowledge program
or an obfuscated program and then just
send it to you right and then you can
run it and gain the benefit of that
computation without having to talk to me
anymore that's right there's
non-interactive nature the
non-interactive nature but with
verification
verifiability in it
sometimes when for example when you have
multi-protocol exchange that's it you
know just like random numbers showed up
you have to
enter the random number as a
participation authentication right now
yeah clearly i think in blockchain they
also began to incorporate more uh their
knowledge proof in the ledger we're
definitely at this
moment now where
zero knowledge is going to be used more
and more there's so many
uh conferences and meetings that that
occur in the zero knowledge space where
you and i are not invited because it's
for the people who are who are
developing it the people who are
programming not as mathematicians yes
yes and i think that's a sign that's a
sign that
our baby has grown up and you know it's
time for it to
be developed i think profoundly the
students often also ask me what are the
future direction both in terms of crypto
zero knowledge proof in the real world
and how mathematically you see in
computing it's a great question i know i
wish i could see the future i i can't
actually but let me try the part of that
that i'm the most comfortable answering
is of course the mathematical side i
think that there is you know we've done
so much in cryptography over the last
few decades
but we understand so little you know
even today we understand so little and i
think the most fundamental
aspect of that is understanding hardness
how do we get hard problems how do we
actually build mathematically hard
problems so that we can then use them
to build efficient zero-knowledge
programs and efficient or knowledge
proofs right i guess also with quantum
computing you need even harder problems
indeed absolutely you know now that we
have we have the specter of quantum
computing coming at us and we all know
that quantum computers can break a lot
of cryptographics that's profound
challenge it's a profound challenge so
can we find
new sources of hardness that are quantum
resistant even quantum computers can't
break and that's something i've been
working on for the last several years
but i'd be very excited to see what
happens in that in that space but i'm
sure they will motivate
beautiful mathematics yes that's right
you know one of the great things about
the real world
is that people in the real world have
demands and those demands often sound
impossible and that's where we come in
it's our job to make the impossible
possible